hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this may very well be the last part
of the cursed forest this amazing free
horror game may be coming to a close
sorry my checkpoint started back there
so I had to cross the bridge again
anyway I'm coming up on Oh
I thought I needed to run really quickly
or run really slowly cuz they'll be
expecting me to run fast
is this really this amazing I know you
can't go back and all but maybe I'm
supposed to loom over the ends and watch
something pull me over okay it's not a
size it's not see I I told need to
combine tits vite its are rather
rambunctious damn look at this it's
raining now and still not a hit to the
performance that is beautiful
Oh even the ground is glistening then
again my computer right now it's like
three times so more powerful than my
computer back home so it's not that
amazing that it's running that well
anymore
how is in the ever still I can applaud
it now someone informed me that a lot of
it is that a voice or was that just a
hooting of an owl you never tell anymore
someone informed me that a lot of these
things are just standard with the
CryEngine 3 development kit what I mean
it's one thing to have a big toolbox
that builds it for you it's another
thing to have a box full of
miscellaneous Lego bricks and assembling
it into something really quite
interesting so I'm not gonna detract
from any efforts that would made from
that okay so I got light over there I
got a path going over there and I got a
house right in front of me let's go into
the house listen Durkin here what what
could that be I thought I got everything
hand there's no
oh it's dark in here abysmal Dooku
what is that what is that like a main
stop kick turn lead I know you okay so
that looks like a ritualistic stone
circle thing I'm assuming I'm supposed
to go over there and jam my bones into
the ground and smash him with stones
yeah yeah this I had a feeling
insert bones okay why not oh it made us
Skellington I never would have suspected
it
Oh got those two sapphire of it so uh so
what about this so I see these holes ah
there we are
so if I just got to find the
corresponding places it won't let me put
anything in and spamming my Oh
okay good this is good I feel good about
this that's good I like this bringing
back someone to life doesn't want to be
brought back it's probably gonna be a
twist that the whole time I was supposed
to trust the shadow he's trying to stop
me from doing something bad I'm really
the evil person come on come on I saw it
it was right there there we go
a little finicky okay bull beans is nice
I like this
all my knees
Alex nice
which today
what is it oh hi you're so beautiful
going up into the swirling vortex in the
Scout cake
I can move now but Oh incredibly slowly
okay
there seems to be some sort of finality
music going on but why what did what did
I do
I have no idea what I just did what do
you mean it's beginning to crumble the
forest was mr. woods
the forests are beginning to couple that
does not look happy okay
oh just meander my way slowly over the
rules over there no there's something
over there I want to see I want to see
what this is
the guy exploded ah I probably should i
what this was way sooner no okay
damn it I'm gonna have to go I'll
fast-forward through that part but I
want to see what's over here like there
was a glow down in the cave by the river
and I need to find out what it was
I'm assuming that it's just not gonna
let me go that way as that's gonna gonna
you're gonna fall down
okay what is you what is you whoa okay
out damn I can't go that way
fine I'll play your game and I'll do the
thing and then I'll get over there get
be back in two seconds get out of that
thing
[Music]
there we go okay we're getting a crumble
why would they put the checkpoint before
all that went down why would they waste
my time come on let's go come on no time
no time no time
we gotta get gone baby gotta be gone
long gone okay oh this way I suppose ago
I think there's a boat over there I'm
gonna make sure was logical scent bowls
with the other pass over there I didn't
get to see everything you killed me too
soon
oh I keep thinking I see the teddy bear
at work
Oh No hopefully it's crumbling I can't
be bothered those just sit here and
relax and kick back and have a 6-pack
[Music]
Tahu nómine hope Olson obey Kabul Umair
monk you know okay so obviously I can't
read any of this but if I had worn a
guess it's saying markiplier played this
game and is air for therefore the
greatest linguist and player of games
ever made in the entirety of reality
it's not good English like that's not me
though I've read that forward forward
that's what it said this guy he doesn't
know English anyway so this was I'm
guessing that's the end the curse forest
which was absolutely fantastic I loved
it from start to finish well a few parts
in there that could have been better but
I mean for the work of probably one
maybe a handful of people that was
stellar I can't read any of that but I
see like I think I see like four names
there but those guys absolutely awesome
I wish there was a way to support these
guys because what they have made here's
just us punishing this is just fantastic
like I would pay many many dollars not
that many but I mean many many dollars
for an experience that was probably
about a little over an hour long I
probably missed some things I was taking
it slow but I mean I've always tell some
things that I missed like a little itty
bitty nuances here and there but either
way I just wanted to talk through the
entirety of the credits to see if I
absolutely got everything and it looks
like I did unless there's something else
that you want to show me game nope that
is it okay so the author is kpy 30 what
a strange name but either way that was
amazing thank you so much for making an
awesome experience I recommend everyone
play for themselves see if you can find
a secret that I didn't find
it's creepy it looks great it plays
great could I have a sprint button in
there whose little tedious to play
through some parts at the walking pace
but other than that it made when you're
going through it and you don't die very
nice
pacing wise baby the way that's the only
complaint I have otherwise not very good
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
apparently I both need to go down there
and I don't see the subjective something
boom without a body